let's see if we can factor 36 a to the
eighth plus two B to the sixth power and
I encourage you to pause the video and
try it out on your own so let's see if
we can express this or re Express this
as the difference of squares using
imaginary numbers so we can rewrite 36
as six squared and a to the eighth is
the same thing as a to the fourth
squared and so let me actually just
write it this way we could rewrite it as
6a to the fourth squared that's this
first term right over here and then the
second term we can write we can write it
as actually let me just write it this
way first plus I'm just writing as a
square plus square root of two B to the
third power squared now we wanted to
write it as a difference of squares so
instead of it writing it this way let's
get rid of this plus and let's so let me
clear that out and I could write it as
subtracting subtracting a negative one
times that and negative one we know is
the same thing as I squared so we can
rewrite this whole thing as 6a to the
fourth squared and then we have this
minus right over here - and so this is I
squared negative 1 is I squared so we
can rewrite this in this pink color as I
times the square root of 2 times B to
the third all of that squared notice I
squared is negative 1 square root of 2
squared is 2 B to the third squared is B
to the sixth power if I raise something
to an exponent then raise it to another
exponent I would multiply the two
exponents and so now I've expressed it
as a difference of squares there's a
difference of squares so we're ready to
factor this is going to be equal to 6 a
to the fourth minus minus minus I times
the square root of 2 times B to the
third times and let me get myself some
space here
times six a to the fourth six a to the
fourth plus plus all of this business I
times the square root of two times B to
the third power and we are done